There's a philosophy in web development.
New browser technologies
cannot break old websites.
Once a site has been built with
stable web standard technologies.
It should continue to work forever.
HTML, CSS, and
JavaScript have evolved quite a bit.
We're currently on HTML version five.
Hence the five there.
And we're also on CSS version three,
notice the three.
And we usually call these HTML5 and
CSS3.
Each new version has added new
features to the markup languages.
But few if any at all,
features have been removed.
So, any website written for
browsers in 94, 95, or really any time,
should look exactly the same
on browsers developed in 2016.
As a result of adding more and
more features to these languages,
there are lots of ways to
solve problems on the web.
And here are just a few that
you'll be learning about soon.
But over time, best practices change.
But that doesn't mean that
yesterday's best practices just stop
working overnight.
Part of being a web developer
is staying up to date and
being able to discern old from new.
Or last year's gold standard
from tomorrow's tech.
Now, to be fair with these examples
in particular, all of these are very,
very valid ways to develop websites.
But there are some differences and
some features are newer than others.
In fact, web technologies
are constantly changing.
New ones are popping up all the time and
even the stable ones are changing
on a scale of weeks, it seems like.
And as I said before,
we can't possibly teach you
everything that there is to know about
the world wide web's technologies.
Instead, we want to teach
you how to stay up to date.
We want you to develop opinions about
new technologies as they come out.
And we want you to keep learning so
that you keep having fun, and
you keep building websites.